it's no longer a matter of if now it's
only a matter of when
despite buying nothing else like this I
fear who wants to come they will be
ready to face what lies still in the
darkness they have to me I'll make sure
Sarah takes care of that
welcome to the interstellar warfare
initiative the current facility is
comprised of several sub levels of
warfare research and development with
larger arenas designed to Train the
human assets of the interest cellar
warfare initiative these arenas are
designed to pay to fire teams against
one another in a variety of assignments
simulating difference and darkness and
weather conditions
constantly changing dynamic environment
operatives are forced to adapt their
strategies and approach the interstellar
Marines trained here will be very few
but capable of changing the tight of a
battle with fire teams of only four
operators
these are just the first steps in
preparation for the full-scale
interstellar warfare division as members
of ite OHS Committee on military
applications budget our initiative only
requires your approval requires your
approval requires your approval
requires your approval requires your
approval